okay your turn okay
[Music]
this is mine that's not weird it
weird because if you're from the south
you understand that pickles are a part
of our life yeah and the juice after you
it's like the top so growing up I would
go to this little snow cone stand and
they had pickled snow cones with pieces
of Grape God my mouth it was so good
yeah I don't know but every time I do it
at home my friends don't really like it
and it's definitely not good on a date
to do I'm 100 yeah
um I'm in I think that sounds awesome
and why aren't snow cones here is my
question I don't know I remember going
to the movies for the first time like
can I have a pickle and they're like
What's that yeah they don't get the
large deal yeah that's weird like they
didn't they do that in the South also
what we do in the south is snow cones do
you know how much people here would love
a snow cones should we have a snow cone
stand I just I think a lot of people
here in the bereft childhood just never
had a snow cone like it's a big thing
and a pickle juice one that could be
named Selena that's the Selena okay
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]